هذه احدى المظاهرات التي خرجت في فرنسا
خرجت هنا في العاصمه الفرنسيه انطلقت من
ساحه الجمهوريه باتجاه ساحه الباستي
المتظاهرون يطالبون بوقف اطلاق النار بوقف
الاباده التي تتعرض غزه يطالبون اسرائيل
بالخروج من الاراضي الفلسطينيه ويقولون
بان فلسطين ليست ملكا لاسرائيل وايضا
يطالبون الدول الغربيه بضروره فرض عقوبات
على اسرائيل
هنات هذه المظهره
تهر ما يخلفه الجيش الاسرائيلي من قتل
وتدمير في غزه وهناك الوان كثيره ظهرت في
هذه المظاهره من بينها طبعا الوان جنوب
افريقيا ورفع صور للزعيم جنوب افريقيا
السابق نيلسون مانديلا وهناك ايضا فرنسيون
شاركوا في هذه المظاهره احدهم قال لي انا
في هذه المظاهره ق لابني لم اكن ابدا
متواطئا مع الاباده نوردين بوزيان الجزيره
[موسيقى]
باريس